the famous sales of the Sydney Opera
House these days so often shrouded in
smoke are now a canvas carrying messages
of thanks to the firefighters who've
battled the bush fires some losing their
lives the latest victim a 60 year old
forestry worker named Bill Slade bill
was working as a member of a task force
in the anglers rest area and he was
struck by a tree the bush fires have
left many so-called killer trees waiting
to fall landscapes like these are the
new normal in the country's scorching
summer and some Australians are angry
demanding their leaders take action to
address the causes of the crisis now the
embattled prime minister Scott Morrison
has admitted some failures there are
things that I could have handled on the
ground much better these are very raw
emotional environments some prime
ministers of flesh and blood - and how
they engage with people engagements like
this unwanted handshakes and cold
shoulders when confronted by critics
Morrison now says he shouldn't have
holidayed in Hawaii in the heat of the
crisis and after months of equivocating
a clear comment on the links between
climate change and the fires climate
change it is the government's policy has
obviously impacted on the longer hotter
drier summer seasons and that's the
advice we've received and that that is
not contested that is the position of
the government okay let there be no
dispute about that
as the fire call-outs continue the Prime
Minister has promised a Royal Commission
to review the crisis but there's no
announcement of any change to the
country's carbon emissions targets or
its reliance on fossil fuels some
Australians want to see more substance
and less smoke